قالت السويد انها ستجري تعديلات قانونيه
تمنح الشرطه والحكومه صلاحيات لمنع حرق
الكتب المقدسه واكدت ستوكهولم التي واجهت
عاصفه من الانتقادات من دول عربيه
واسلاميه بسبب حوادث حرق نسخ من القران
الكريم عند الاستفزازات التي تستهدف
القران الكريم تحولت الى مشكله خطيره
لامرها وان صورتها في الخارج تغيرت بسبب
هذه الاستفزازات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
كيف نفهم الخطوات التي اعلنت السويد انها
بصدد اتخاذها والى اي حد يمكن ان تعد
تراجعا عن تمسكها بما تعتبره حريه تعبير
توفر ذريعه للسماح بالاعتداء على مقدسات
المسلمين ثم منعكسات هذه الخطوه على نظره
بقيه دول اوروبا للتضارب بين احترام
المقدسات الدينيه وحريه التعبير باعتبارها
احدى الركائز الاساسيه في القيم الاوروبيه
ثم كيف يمكن للدول المسلمه والعربيه
الاستفاده من نتائج ضغط حكوماتها المتزامن
على السويد وتوظيف هذه التجربه لمواجهه
اشكال الانتهاكات الاخرى ضد مقدسات
المسلمين
[موسيقى]
بعد حمله ضغوط وانتقادات رسميه وشعبيه
واثره تلويح باجراءات عقابيه من قبل دول
عربيه واسلاميه ضد ستوكهولم على خلفيه
حوادث حرق نسخ من القران الكريم في السويد
اعلنت الحكومه السويديه انها بصدد اتخاذ
اجراءات تمنح الحكومه والشرطه تمنعهما
تمنحهما مزيدا من الصلاحيات لمنع حرق
الكتب المقدسه من دون ان تمتد تلك
التعديلات تشمل حظر استهداف الكتب المقدسه
رئيس الوزراء السويدي اقر في مؤتمر صحفي
مع وزير العدل بان الاستفزازات التي
تستهدف القران الكريم تحولت الى مشكله
امنيه خطيره في البلاد وان الصوره الذهنيه
للسويد تغيرت في العالم الخارجي لما بات
يمثل تحديدا يوازي التحديات التي تفرضها
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ومهددات انضمام
ببلاده لحلف شمال الاطلسي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع معنا من
ستوكهولمان استاذ العلوم السياسيه المختص
بتسويه النزاعات بجامعه ومن باريس صلاح
القادر الباحث في قضايا العالم العربي
والاسلامي اهلا بكم وابدا بضيف من السيد
عن كيف وجد هذه الاجراءات المتخذه من قبل
الحكومه السويديه ولما الان لما لم يتم
اتخاذها من قبل تجنبا لمقاله الحكومه
بانها سبب لقيامها بهذه الاجراءات
شكرا على دعوتكم السلام عليكم
على اثري النقاشات في مساله التعديلات
الاطر القانونيه كان هنالك رساله او
الاساسيه انه حسب علمي انه كان سيكون هناك
نقاشات من اجل اجراء اصلاحات قانونيه من
اجل منع اي انتهاكات قد تصل الى جرائم
الكراهيه وهذا ليس بالضروره يعني انه
الاجراءات التي ستكون
ستكون هنالك منع مستقبلا اعتقد ان هذا
سياتي مستقبلا وهذا بالتالي ليس من الواضح
ما الذي ستقوم به الحكومه قد تكون هذه
العمليه طويله الامد وايضا البرلمان
والحكومه سيتم نقاشها فيها بالتالي ليس
هنا ليس هنالك وضوح تماما سيحصل مستقبلا
الامر سيتطلب بعض الوقت بالنسبه
للدول العربيه ستكسب اي شيء لا اعتقد ذلك
اعتقد ان هنالك سوء لف سيحدث اذ ان تم
تصوير السويد على انها دول
معاديه للاسلام او لديها كراهيه للاسلام
اعتقدوا ان هنالك هذا امر غير صحيح هذه
نسبه صغيره فقط في المجتمع بالتالي هذه
مشكله صغيره ليس هنالك اسلامه فاضيه في
السويد بالتالي من المحزن ان هنالك الكثير
من
الحملات الاعلاميه هنالك
حملات اعلاميه ضد السويد هذه فقط حادثه
منفرده وفي الحقيقه الامر ان من المؤسف
انه يكون
اعتقد ان من على الدول ان هذه الدول ان
تقوم بحمايه قوانينها
والديمقراطيه في السويد نحن
قمنا بذلك منذ سنوات وسنستمر بذلك كيف
وجدت هذه الاجراءات المتخذه من قبل
الحكومه السويديه وقبلها الجانب الدنماركي
هل هي كفيله بحل هذا الاشكال مستقبلا وعدم
تكراره
بدايه سيدي الكريم ان يجب ان ننظر الى هذه
الاجراءات على انها لم تتحول الى قوانين
هي بازال خطاب نوايا ونوايا حسنه نظنها
كذلك لكن
القوانين الاوروبيه حينما هناك حتى تتحول
الى قوانين قد تصبح سته اشهر قد سنه يجب
المرور على البرلمان يجب صياغتها من طرف
الحكومه عرضها على البرلمان
الانزال الى المجتمع المدني والنظر كيف
يتقبلها الراي العام السويدي او الدنماركي
اذا لذلك يجب ان نتعامل مع هذه
التطورات بحذر وان ننتظر حتى تتحول الى
اجراءات قانونيه قابله للتنفيذ بشكل مباشر
اولا ثانيا اظن ان هذه النوايا الحسنه
خطاب النوايا الحسنه او الاجراءات
المحتمله من طرف الحكومه الدنماركيه او
الحكومه السويديه هي بالاساس رد فعل على
تحركات الدبلوماسيه خصوصا اجتماع الوزراء
خارجيه
التعاون الاسلامي دول التعاون الاسلامي
والتي التي التي طالبت بالسويد والدنمارك
وحددت هاتين الدولتين بوقف الاجراءات
العدائيه التي تتم الان تجاهها الاكثر
المصدر الاكثر الاكثر قداسه لدى المسلمين
الذي هو القران الكريم لذلك اظن ان هذا
الموقف ليس ليس
ناتجا فقط عن قضيه حقوقيه او انسانيه بقدر
ما هو حسابات مصالح من طرف الحكومه
السوريه
صلاح القادري كما
قال عدنا المقاطعه حتى وان كان كما قلت ما
زال الى الان خطاب نوايا من حيث الشكل من
حيث الفكره هل تراها كفيله بنزع فتيل هذه
الازمه
نعم هي الى الان هي رسائل طمانه لكن
الانتظار تتحول الى قوانين لان الاشكاليه
هي ليست مع الدول ذات الغالبيه المسلمه
الاشكاليه هي اشكاليه داخليه كما قال وزير
الداخليه السويدي الاشكاليه اليوم هو ان
هناك اشكاليه سلم اجتماعي حينما حصلت الان
تحصل توترات بين المجتمع السويدي او
المجتمع الدينيماركي وبين اقليه من
المواطنين السويديين لا نتكلم عن مهاجرين
فقط نحن نتكلم عن مواطنين السويديين من
اصحاب الديانه المسلمه الذين يحسون الان
بانهم يتعرضون ان هناك معادات للاسلام بان
هناك اجراءات عنصريه وفاشيه وشعبويه في
حقهم هذا ما يؤدي الى ضرب السلم الاجتماعي
داخل دوله مجتمع هادئ سابقا وعاده مثل
المجتمع السويدي او الدنماركي من مصلحه
الاساسه الاتراك سواء كانوا ساسه الرسميين
او ساسه الحزبيين اعاده النظر في هذه
القوانين لان حريه التعبير لا تعني
الكراهيه وجرائم الكراهيه في حق الاخرين
الان هناك اشكاليه كبيره على على على حساب
مفهوم الحريه هناك
بهذه الطريقه عدم التصدي لهاته الاجراءات
هو خدمه لاجنده اليمين المتطرف الذي هو في
تصاعد في الدنمارك وفي بقيه الدول
الاوروبيه ويجب على العقلاء في هذه الدول
الاوروبيه سواء كانوا اعلاميين ام مفكرين
ام ساسا ان ينتبهوا الى هذه المساله
الخطيره اثرت نقطه مهمه سيده صلاح القاضي
هنا اسال ضيف السيد
قبل قليل قلت هناك سوء فهم ليس هناك اسلام
فوبيا في السويد وانما جرى فعل فردي عندما
تتحرك كل هذه الدول الاسلاميه على راسها
منظمه المؤتمر الاسلامي وكل هذه
الاحتجاجات بما فيها المسلمين في السويد
ومع ذلك الطرف الاخر ما زال يرى بان هذا
الفعل فردي ومحدود ويتعلق بالحريه
هناك اذا مشكله ما نحتاج الى فهمها لماذا
التباين في الموقفين
[موسيقى]
اريد ان ارى ادله عما يسمى بالاسلام لان
السويد ترحب باللاجئين من دول
يكون فيه الاسلام هو الدين الاساسي لماذا
تقوم بهذا السويد اذا ما كان هنالك اسلام
فوبيا منتشره بين سكان السويد وانا قمت
بقياس هذا الامر في بحثي ومن الحكومه ايضا
بالتالي في حسب رايي
حاله من الحمله الدعائيه الحزينه التي
يحاول فيها الاشخاص ان يقوموا
بوضع مجموعات مجتمعيه مختلفه من اجل خلف
صدام بينهم بالتالي علينا ان نتخذ نتخذ
الحذر ايضا الشيء الثاني الذي يظهر هنا ان
رد الفعل على العنف لاننا راينا هجوما على
السفاره السويديه في العراق هذا في حقيقه
الامر ادى الى
دفعه بالحكومه السويديه ان لا تستمع الى
المطالب التي قدمها قاده
الدين لانه اذا ما صاحب هذا الامر الارهاب
او اعمال العنف لا يمكنهم ان يستمعوا الى
هذا الامر لانهم في حقيقه الامر قد يخلق
ما المزيد من المشاكل بالتالي الكثير من
الاطراف تتصرف
بعنفهم يضعون انفسهم في الزاويه وهم لا
يحاولوا التوصل الى حل سلمي او الى نوع من
التفاهم وانا اعمل باخلاص ان المواطنين
وحكومات الدول العربيه عليها ان تفكر فيما
تريد ان تحققه صلاح القادري مفهوم الحريه
مقدس في الدول الغربيه اذا لماذا يتم وصف
ما يجري في اطار تقديس الحريه باصباغه
بنوايا كما قال ضيفي يا سيد
بالحديث عن الاسلام فوبيا في دوله السويد
كما يقول تستقبل كل سنه العديد من
المسلمين
استقبال وترحيب السويد والمسلمين هذا
موضوع يطول ولكننا اذكر فقط الاجراءات
الظالمه التي تعرضت لها المئات ان لم اقل
الالاف من العائلات اللاجئين المسلمين
الذين هم في الذين هم في السويد والذين
تحولوا ابنائهم الى تجاره مع المصلحه
الاجتماعيه والموضوع يطول وهناك تحقيقات
وهناك شهادات كبيره لصحافه الاستقصائيه
التي ابانت على ان هناك اراده لتهديد
المسلمين الذين يعيشون في السويد اذ الذي
يريد ان يهاجر الى السويد عليه ان يتحمل
لانه في اي لحظه من اللحظات ان تاخذ
الدوله السويديه منه اعز ما يملك وهم
ابناءه هذه الملاحظه الاولى الملاحظه
الثانيه سيدي الكريم حينما يتكلمون عن
الحريه ان نتكلم عن شيء بسيط جدا هذا
المهاجر العراقي الذي قام العراق ولا يمثل
العراقيين هو يمثل نفسه الذي قام بحرق
المصحف الكريم المصحف الشريف لو قام هذا
الرجل بح العلم السويدي سيرحل في اليوم
بنفسه وسيصدر فيه قرار نافذ في اليوم نفسه
لا احد يتكلم عن حريه التعبير حين ذاك
حينما تحرق العلم السويدي حينما تحرق
الدستور السويدي لا توجد حريه انذاك هذه
جريمه كراهيه واعتداء على مقدسات وعلى
ثوابت الامه السويديه لكن حينما نحرق
المصحف الشريف نحن هنا نمارس الحريه هنا
فرق وهو فرق والعقلاء وحتى البسطاء من
السويديين يعرفون ذلك وجميع الاوروبيين
لان هذا منطق انساني من حقك ان ترى بان
الاسلام ليس دينا من حقيقه ان ترى بان
الله غير موجود من حقك ان ترى ان هذا الذي
هو القران الكريم هو كتاب المؤلف ومحرف من
النصرانيه واليهوديه وهو في كتاب الفه
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم هذا امر يخصك هذه
حريه تفكير وحريه تعبير حينما تتكلم لكن
حينما تعتدي على مسجد حينما تعتدي على
مصلي على مؤمن حينما تعدد تحرق القران
الكريم انت لا تعبر عن بحريه عن فكرك انت
هنا تعتدي على حريه الاخرين لو قام احد
الناس بحرق العلم
المثليين سوف ماذا سيعتبر هذا هل يعتبر
حريه في السويد لن يعتبر حريه بل سيعتبر
جريمه كراهيه وعداء ضد المثليين حينما
تحرق العالم السويدي حينما تحرق يمكن
يعطيك عشره او اكثر من الامثله الان
مسؤوليه في الحين
ايضا وانقل له ايضا
التساؤل عن بهذه الاجراءات التي يتم او
ينوي الجانب او الحكومه السويديه
الاتخاذها الا يعد هذا مساسا بفكره تقديس
الحريه التي على اساسها سمح لكل هؤلاء
باحراق نسخ من القران الكريم
ارغب بالاجابه على مزعم ان الاطفال يتم
اخذهم من
المهاجرين من قبل الحكومه السويديه هذه
حمله دعائيه بدات منذ سنوات عديده ويقوم
بها ارهابيون يهدفون الى نشر الذعر
والكراهيه في المجتمع السويدي وبين
المهاجرين خصوصا هم يريدوا ان يحيدوا
الانتباه من قبل مجموع المجموعات على
معينه لنا وفي الوقت الذي تحاول فيه
الحكومه السويديه ان تساعد هم سمحوا لهم
بالدخول الى السويد كلاجئه لماذا تسمح
الحكومه لاشخاص بالدخول الى البلد وبعد
ذلك تختطف اولادهم هذه خرافه هذه فقط حمله
دعائيه تهدف الى التحريض الى العنف الضيف
الزميلي الذي يتحدث اعتقد انه يستخدم حمله
دعائيه
الناجحه بما انك اشرت لنقطه مهمه وحساسه
لماذا وصفت من يحتجون على فصل الابناء عن
عائلاتهم في السويد لانهم ارهابيون على اي
اساس
ليس هنالك اي اساس هنالك
موقف غير عادل تجاه الحكومه الخدمه
الاجتماعيه لا تقوم بخطف الاطفال
ارهابي هذا توصيف خطير وبالتالي على اي
اساس اسميتها هؤلاء من يحتجون على فصل
الابناء عن ذويهم بانهم انه سلوك ارهابي
او فعل ارهابي او انهم ارهابيون
انا لم انا لم اقل ان
الاشخاص الذين يقومون بالاحتجاج هم
ارهابينا لكن اقول ان الاشخاص الذين
يقومون بنشر هذه الاخبار الكاذبه هذا عمل
ارهابي لانه يحقق يخلق انشقاقا في المجتمع
ويستهدف الحكومه السويديه طيب صلاح
القادري اذا يعني انت اثرت المساله
وبالتالي لك حق الرد تفضل
ليست
نعم سيدي الكريم هنا مثال بسيط جدا
للتناقض وهنا التناقض هو تناقض صارخ مجرد
اني وصفت ان تصرف الحكومه
السويديه تجاه العائلات المسلمه بانه
الغرض منه هو دفع كل عائله مسلمه تفكر في
اللجوء الى السويد ان تخاف على اولادها
وصف للرجل بالارهابي هذا الرجل مجرد مجرد
نقد الحكومه السويديه بالنسبه له ارهاب
وانا امارس حريه تعبير بينما في الوقت
ذاته يعتبر حرق القران الكريم هو مجرد
ومجرد مجرد تعبير عن حريه حريه تفكير
وحريه تعبير هذا هو الكيل بامكانين هذا هو
الكيلو بامكاني بمثال واضح امام المشاهد
العربي الذي يشاهد الجزيره هنا مثقف سويدي
يقول ان تنتقد الحكومه السويديه في
تعاملها مع العائلات المسلمه في ملف
اطفالها يعتبر ارهابا بينما حرق مصحف شريف
يمثل اقدس شيء لدى امه توجد بقرابه مليار
ونصف العالم هذا مجرد حريه التعبير طيب
وصلت الفكره ايضا رايته يعلق على كلامك
باختصار ولكن ارجو ان تجيبني على فكره
الحريه مقابل هذه الاجراءات المتخذه من
قبل او تنوي الحكومه السويديه اتخاذها الم
تعد الحريه مقدسه كما كانت الحجه في
السابق
اريد القول اذا ما قمتم بمتابعه هذه
الحمله دعائيه حول الاطفال وخطفهم انتم
تخلقون
انشقاقا وخلافات في المجتمع
وهي مروعه
اذا ما اخذنا بنظر اعتبار التاثير على
الناس الذين يعيشون في اسود وكيف ان من
المنطقي على الحكومه ان تقوم بذلك في
الوقت نفس الوقت نحن نرحب باللاجئين
والمهاجرين من بلاد الاسلام لماذا نقوم
بخطف الاطفال ليس هنالك اي اسس لهذا الامر
هذه فقط حمله دعائيه غير حقيقيه وهي تهدف
لخلف الصرع بالتالي الناس يظهرون على
شاشات التلفاز مثل ما يظهرون الان على
الجزيره وهم يقومون بايجادي وخلق الصراع
وهم يقحمون حقوق المثليين باي حوار
ويقولون ان هنالك معايير مزدوجه لماذا
يتحدث دائما هنالك حديث عن حقوق المثليين
عندما يكون هنالك جدل حول حريه
هل لك ان تجيبني على سؤالي فيما يتعلق
بموضوع الحريه وهذه الاجراءات التروي
الحكومه السويديه
بامكان هذا الامر ان يقوم بذلك لان هنالك
عندما ننظر الى الحقوق حقوق حريه التعبير
وايضا فيما يتعلق بحقوق الاحتجاج الامر قد
يخرق حقوقا اخرى نعم هنالك صدام بين القيم
وهذا امر صعب ان نخلق التوازن بينه لكن
انما نتحدث عن الاحتجاجات الرمزيه هي لا
تستهدف الاشخاص لكنها تستهدف الافكار
والافكار مرتبطه بحريه التعبير بالتالي ما
دام لدينا قانون في السويد ينص على اننا
لدينا حريه التعبير هذا الامر سيسمح
بالانتقاد والهجمات وايضا الاعمال الرمزيه
المروعه كما راينا في السويد الان ضد
القران وضد الاسلام لكنه لا يستهدف
المسلمين في صلاح القادري هل باعتقادك هذا
الضغط في الدول الاسلاميه هو الذي اثمر
هذه الخطوه ايضا هل بالامكان استثمار هذا
الضغط ايضا في قضايتهم المسلمين مثل ما
يحدث في المقدسات في المسجد الاقصى
والاختراقات الاسرائيليه مره بعد مره هل
يمكن الاستثمار في هذا المجهود في قضايا
اخرى تهم المسلمين
الكل يعرف الدول القويه والدول الغربيه هي
هي تفكر بمنطق برغماتي وبنطق المصلحه فاذا
رات ان مصلحتها مهدده
ستتراجع عن هذه القرارات اليوم هم يقبلون
بهذه التصرفات الفاشيه والتي هي افكار
تمثل افكار اليمين المتطرف يعني يمين
المتطرف هو الكتله الانتخابيه الاكثر
فعاليه في السويد في السنوات الاخيره فهم
يقبلون بمثل هذه التصرفات كساسه حزبيين
اساسه رسميين لان هناك مصلحه الوصول الى
السلطه حينما يعرفون ان مصالح السويد
الخارجيه الاقتصاديه خصوصا هي مهدده وكذلك
خلق توترات مع دول قد تقارب عددها المئه
في العالم
وانتشار صوره الحقيقيه عن السويد على انه
يسمح باجراءات وجرائم كراهيه في حق
الاسلام وهي حرق المصحف الشريف حين ذلك
حينما توضع في ميزان المصالح بين المصلحه
والمفسده اعرف ان الاساس وغيرهم من اساس
الاوروبيين سيختارون مصلحتهم وهي المصلحه
الان التي تكون مصلحه في المشاريع
الاقتصاديه او في وجود علاقات دبلوماسيه
مع هذه الدول التهديد بسحب التمثيليات
الدبلوماسيه او قطع والغاء العقود
التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع هذه الدول مع
الابقاء على قنوات الحوار مع الدبلوماسيه
مع هاته الدول هاته الوسائل الحقيقيه
واللازمه من اجل حفظ مصالح هذه الدول
الاسلاميه وخصوصا
دفع هذه الدول الى عدم الاعتداء على
المقدسات التي هي مقدسات المسلمين سواء
كانت مقدسات المسلمين او اليهود او
المسيحيين مقدسات اي انسان معتقدات هي شيء
مقدس لا يجب المساس به تحت الحريه
سواء في السويد او في دول اوروبيه اخرى ما
قد يراه تراجعا عن ما يسمونه بقيم
يؤمنون بها يستثمرها في زياده جرعه اليمين
في هذه الدول
اظن ان المسلم ان ان المواطنين الاوروبيين
الذين هم من اصحاب الديانه المسلمه يجب ان
يلعبوا دورهم كذلك من خلال وسائل الاعلام
وان يتحولوا كذلك الى كتله انتخابيه
سياسيه وازنه وبالتالي تصبح هذه الاحزاب
السياسيه تحسب لهم الف حساب وبالتالي
سيتراجع اليمين المتطرف اليمين المتطرف
ككتله انتخابيه لا يمثل غالبيه لكنه يمثل
شعره الميزان في الانتخابات يجب ان ان
المواطنين المسلمون ان يمارسوا حقهم
الانتخابي ونظارهم السياسي وان يدافعوا من
خلال نظام سلمي عن حقوقهم وعن معتقداتهم
وعن وعن
واعتذر منك سيد صلاح القادر الباحث
القضايا القضايا العالم العربي والاسلامي
وكذلك الشكر ضيفي من
ستوكهولمان الاستاذ العلوم السياسيه
المختص بتسويه النزاعات بجامعه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]